well uh congratulations you finally won
a game
well I want to ask you about how did you
sleep this night or not after a special
after yesterday's game ah you know when
I played first time this case cup uh I
had a terrible insomnia so that's why
now I am more prepared and I have some
pills for sleeping so I can say that I
slept well
so well for this was a very interesting
moment in your game I wanted to ask you
how did you feel about the this position
did you know that you were not worse
even though you were born down uh yeah I
know because as I remember there was a
game like this probably
topalo played I don't remember exactly
but I know that it's about equal so
that's why I decided to play this end
game so you were quite confident at that
stage yeah but after Rook D3 uh
I was not sure about taco no 23 but then
I liked this plan C5 C4 I had a counter
play I think
of course it was a very nice position
then I think that it was balanced and
here I have a question because we I know
that you're very tired and that it took
you uh
oh your last forces to calculate here
and Rook seat yes that was very much did
you consider this move C3 yes at first I
was going to place a three but it takes
C3 B takes A3 and the King did
and there was a very beautiful move here
Knight C4 Rook A4 and here I don't know
I don't that was the move that was
winning actually yes
[Music]
no I missed a lot
it was not easy it's not obvious but you
played very well and I think that this
position is uh already lost yes but
anyway I could win easily I think I
missed just just
um
so and so
I was very tired yes and this of course
so well that was quite a long game we
will not keep you in the studio and I
hope to have you back
me too listen thank you very much Bella
our congratulations indeed very very
nice game and so important